[Music]
do you have any names to share no I've
been thinking I want this baby to have a
normal life look child will be heir to
the kingdom still I went to public
school and I was riding the subway by
myself when I was 10
we'll find a new definition of normal
together there's subway riding well
luckily for you Aldo via doesn't have a
subway tonight your Majesties the truce
between Aldo via and pain Lea I'll be
the first Queen to sign it pregnant are
quite traditional we the Queen's could
bring the treaty up to date you wish to
modernize our 600 year old tradition
history isn't made by those who follow
rules may I also offer our service I
have seen the artifact it's a bit tacky
it's a priceless work of art it is my
honor to preside over the sacred truth
let the signing begin perhaps now can be
replaced with something more palatable
who in this palace had the means the
opportunity the motive
if the sake of truce is broken there'll
be a curse on the firstborn child if the
treaty isn't signed by midnight
Christmas Eve it takes effect the treaty
is missing and if we don't find it our
baby is cursed you're gonna have to
explain that one it's a long story
emphasis on story I'll be on the first
legend Oh could you please bring me some
bagels don't judge my cravings
[Music]
it's going to be fun
[Music]
I don't know if I'm ready to be a queen
and a mom
the plane is standing by would dupatta
first clearing I know you don't believe
in the curse but right now I need your
help
we'll leave no stone unturned no one
does Christmas like the Aldo viens
[Music]
what is it I can't even reach my own
slippers
hanami perfect fit
[Music]
you
you